c'est une garderie familiale
subventionnés comme il en existe des
centaines au québec
c'est ici que pendant des années
jennyfer vannetais ont déposé leur fille
tous les matins confiant comme on dépose
les enfants chez leur grand pas ça fait
peur mais le 20 octobre dernier
l'inimaginable est arrivé un matin les
pyjamas qu'il me dit papa si je te juste
eu raconte une histoire je te dise la
vérité tout dans le car est juste bien
sûr et elle me raconte ce qui passait la
journée qui a été barrée dans une salle
de bains et pis agressée sexuellement
par un adolescent qui visait la garde de
leur fille l'inventaire y est elle est
deux autres fillettes ont été laissées
seules ou sous sol alors que la
responsable des services de garde et son
assistant préparer le dîner un étage
plus haut c'est tout ce qu'il a fallu
pour que visiteur de treize ans ans
ferme deux des fillettes dans une salle
de bains dévasté ils ont aussitôt
contacté la police
ils ont porté plainte auprès du bureau
coordonnateur de la région pour qu'ils
sévissent immédiatement contre la
garderie après enquête le bureau leur a
répondu que la responsable des services
de garde a contrevenu à la loi en
laissant les enfants sans surveillance
ou sous sol en agissant ainsi elle a mis
en péril leur sécurité
le bien-être des enfants une faute
impardonnable disent les parents mais
des sanctions bonbons oui la guerre
dialyse ont laissé seul
les pénalités sont vendeurs s'étaient on
va le surveiller de plus près aucun
recours additionnel on enlève de repos
les parmi la gardienne quand
l'adolescent plaidé coupable cet hiver
les parents ont demandé une révision de
la planète
le bureau coordonnateur leur a dit qu'il
était trop tard et invoque la loi selon
laquelle monsieur carreaux devait
présenter un autre fait contre la
gardienne que l'aso subis par leur fille
quoique graves et reconnus n'est pas
imputable à la gardienne jo 9h28 refuse
d'accepter ses conclusions il faut que
quelqu un responsable pour les enfants
explique sans à moi ministère de la
famille qui était responsable
ce jour l'eau ou la négligence n'a pas
juste mon enfant de trois enfants
ce jour là le couple exige des sanctions
à la hauteur des torts que leur fille a
subi alors qu'il n'était pas surveillée
la galerie continue c'est pas ton
toujours ouvert et les parents
aujourd'hui des autres buts enfants ils
sont pas au courant de ce qui s'est
passé qui concerne toutes les journées
leurs enfants en garderie ou la
gardienne clairement démontré la
négligence du maine et vous tu peux
acheter une maison
tu achète une maison les propriétaires
doit vous aviez tout ce qui est passé
dans cette maison faisant sept enfants
garderie ils y ont pas de rien à dire
l'incident est en effet considéré
confidentielles les garderies familiales
mais que subventionner ne sont pas
soumises aux mêmes règles de
transparence que les cpe les rapports
d'inspection aussi ils ne sont pas
accessibles au grand public
pour la professeur nathalie bigras qui
étudie depuis des années la qualité des
services de garde au québec
le système est opaque et rempli de
failles c'est comme si les services de
garde en milieu familial était était pas
un vrai service de garde comme les
autres ils sont pas soumis aux mêmes
règles aux mêmes lois aux mêmes à la
même formation aux mêmes conséquences
la chercheurs croient que cette histoire
de re servir de sonnette d'alarmé
d'abord aux responsables des services de
garde en milieu familial
il ya trop encore des gens qui banalise
le fait de ne pas surveiller les enfants
pour quelques minutes
il devrait selon elle convaincre le
gouvernement qu'il faut resserrer les
règles qui à son avis sont minimales ça
fait longtemps fait qu'on réclame pour
les services de guerre mieux familiaux
une meilleure formation une formation
plus complète
puis un encadrement aussi un contrôle
une surveillance plus régulière et plus
fréquente est ce qu on nous répond
toujours c'est ce sont des travailleuses
autonomes et c'est exactement ce qui
trouble encore danic érodé sa femme le
sentiment que la loi protège les
entreprises que sont devenus les
garderies familiales et négligent les
parents elle a dû quitter son emploi
pour rester à la maison et assurer la
transition de sa fille vers la
maternelle tous les deux aujourd'hui
interpelle le gouvernement les effets
vont être les deux pendant des années
des années et je n'sais matin chaque
fois qu'elles ferment les yeux le soir
pour les crimes sont là les images de ce
qui s'est passé
on n'était pas là pour protéger notre
affaire
on va s'assurer que les enfants et nos
enfants
jamais vivre cette situation devient
vraiment nous chercher tamara bon la
ministre la famille ne voulait pas
accorder d'entrevues aujourd'hui mais
quand même elle a réagi par écrit et
elle semble prendre cette affaire au
sérieux
oui on nous a dit à son cabinet qu'elle
a été très troublé par ce qu'elle a vu
parce qu'elle a entendu et qu'elle veut
du temps pour se pencher sur ce dossier
là elle est interpellée parce que on a
beau penser ce qu'on veut de la gestion
de ce dossier là par le bureau
coordonnateur
pourquoi ils n'ont pas suspendu permis
même pas le temps d'enquêter pourquoi on
a tout de suite remplacé la place
laissée vacante par cette fillette par
un autre enfant
on a beau penser ce qu'on veut la
réalité c'est que ces décisions là et
ont été prises avec ce que la loi
prescrit avec les régions est exactement
mais justement alors qu'est ce que ça
nous dit qu est ce qu il faut comprendre
le système de garderie au québec parce
que ça soulève tellement de questions et
très peu de réponses pour l'instant ça
nous dit qu'il ya différentes règles
pour des établissements qui grosso modo
à ceux là mêmes responsabilités ça nous
dit aussi qu'il ya peut-être encore trop
de gens aujourd'hui au sein de ce
système qui banalise l'importance de
surveiller d'assurer la surveillance des
enfants en tout temps c'est arrivé
peut-être en quelques minutes mais c'est
arrivé et ça devrait selon certains
experts servir de sonnette d'alarmé et
ça nous pose une question assez
important est ce que c'est possible dans
ce genre d'établissement d'assurer cette
surveillance on ne conclut qu'elle a
enfreint les règles mais est-ce qu'on
peut quand on est seule avec ses enfants
garantir qu'une l'enfant seront toujours
surveiller ce qui fait dire aux parents
et à beaucoup d'observateurs aujourd'hui
qu'il est peut-être temps parce que ça
fait des années qu'on interpelle le
gouvernement de s'asseoir de regarder
les règles et de se poser la question
est ce qu'elles sont suffisantes pour
assurer ce que la loi a vu que l'assuré
c'est la protection et la sécurité blanc
parce qu'il faut dire que ces traversées
ces garderies en milieu familial c'est
considéré comme du travail autonome donc
les travailleurs autonomes sommets
enneigés paris à 7h et humain
si on leur demande plus à ces
travailleuses autonomes là elles vont
réclamer davantage d'argent c'est pour
l'instant le service de garde qui coûte
le moins cher
gouvernement dans tout le système condat
donc est ce qu'il ya des choix
politiques à faire ou est-ce que c'est
simplement une question de resserrer le
contrôle
on attend la réponse de la ministre
alors qu'ils devraient donc réagir plus
en profondeur d'ici les prochains jours
merci beaucoup d'avoir à vous en prie